hello and welcome to this video playing
verdict again he's probably sick of this
i have a really good score
yeah not a another e3 again like a more
slip variation
let's go for the roxy bind my favorite
opening
with white
let's see bishop e6 bishop d7 black has
those basic options
against bishop e6 f4 is a good way to
play
yeah here there the couple of
interesting things one interesting
point is that i can play f5 immediately
and there is this there is a very direct
way of attacking
yeah i will go for that
not quite sure if how good it is
but i think i have tried that before
it's it's at least um very much playable
that that's what i know so i'm giving up
the exchange here he can take my rook
now
but i can take e7 take you on that
that's good for me
the question is what happens if he does
not take yeah
this is the thing he can check me on c5
he takes
wow okay so i can take e7 with
check first right is it
yeah i mean it's just good let's do it
there's really no reason to waste
time i mean this is very very good for
white
queen e5 maybe was better
okay i think i can just take this
and then take g6
just winning the house here
hg6 rook takes f6 should just be
good yeah so go here
okay so i can just take this
take the queen is there a point of not
taking it probably not
i'm already up quite a good chunk of
material
um okay rook d1
yeah let's go into the open file
king to e3
he can play f5 yes to get rid of
maybe um maybe rook d6 is an
idea
it's really not not important
rook f1
i can also i can check here also
i wonder i would like to get the bishop
to d5 that would be technically
very desirable bishop f3 goes e4 though
king to e3 would also be nice but he has
a check
so
i have to think about the best way of
doing this like from a technical point
of view
i can also go c5 in this position
c5b4 yeah these kind of moves will be
useful
[Music]
taking a bit more time here than usual
um and
not usual then necessary actually it's
not such a difficult
technical task but i'd like to
i'd like to be uh thorough okay
now this
yeah now there's no bishop c2 and i
would love to go to e3
bishop g4
king e3 takes takes the rook ending is
excellent yeah yeah we can do that
yeah this is ideal now the king is
great great damn and now just g4
h4 push
push what we have let's say push the
extra material
well no that's not not
too early yeah that that line is is
pretty dangerous
um to put it mildly i mean he defended
um he didn't defend as well but we'll
see
so f5 and the question is can you
if this is i know that bishop takes f6
is not
necessarily the best continuation but i
have played it before and it
it just scores tremendously well so
let's do it but there is a problem i
don't quite remember what it was
rook c8 yeah so black is fine
if he finds the best continuation now
king g7
g7 so this means that
here i can actually do this this is
important right
with the check and now this is
completely fine for black
yeah this is completely fine this is not
all that weakened i mean my structure
sucks so this is a weak pawn and the
bishop is not great and so on
so
this this is also a possibility it seems
yeah so at the end of the day this is
not the best continuation
i think i actually had this in a game
and i played king age one in that game
in a tournament game and if i'm
not mistaken my opponent played some
non-move then like a6 or so
and then uh the whole thing gets a
little bit more interesting because
now there is no check it's very
difficult to
to defend this position yeah in the game
he completely uh lost the plot by taking
when i can just grab and
yeah basically win probably queen e5
now is a better way to defend like just
being one pawn down
the way it it happened i was two pawns
up
and it's it's very very simple
technically yeah here i don't know
there are a couple of things g4 possible
b4 is generally useful
this is helping a little bit just for
practical purposes that
i can conveniently go to e3 and then
you can just be super safe with the king
and just push everything forward without
a worry in the world
so that was helpful for
for conversion yeah thanks a lot for
watching